okay so the government have closed the
schools you're effectively your
children's teacher this might seem a bit
daunting but I'm here to tell you that
it's possible I've been home educating
my children for the last eight years and
working from home here are my top tips
okay so tip number one is don't try and
replicate the school system you can't
and you don't need to the way that your
teachers will be teaching your children
is very different from how you will
teach your children so cast that aside
stop worrying about it teaching the way
that you would teach and in a way that
seats you and your child and don't worry
about what's been happening at school
particularly so tip number two is to do
with timetabling for many of us a
timetable is absolutely essential for
many of us it isn't essential if you do
want to set a timetable so that you can
work alongside your children then make
sure it's one that suits you work it
around your working hours their waking
hours when they're at their most
productive this is a great time to
really get to know your children so if
they are morning people front load the
academic work in the morning have the
afternoon set aside for free play try
and work your working hours around them
and just make it time double that seat -
you don't look on social media at the
timetable that your neighbor has posted
that's all color coded and terrifying
and ownerís just think of one that suits
you and stick to that so tip number
three is about getting outside as much
as you can if you can obviously not all
of us are able to sit in the garden but
remember that playing in the garden
playing in the mud is education
don't try and think that your children
need to be sat at their desks all day
poring over maths books fresh air is
good for you fresh air will make them
learn better it will make you happier
sunshine will be better for them there's
plenty of educational opportunities
outside if you're able to go so get
outside as much as is possible and safe
for you tip number four is to really
value the one-to-one time that this
experience will give you as a ho matter
I don't tend to spend eight hours a day
working one-to-one with my children but
what I do give them is really valuable
short bursts of one-to-one attention so
if there's a maths problem that they're
struggling with I can really sit down
with them explain the concept make sure
they've understood it then send them
away to do it themselves and this is
something that not all children get in
the school system and so this is
something that you can really make the
most of and it doesn't need to take up a
lot of
your day a good friend of mine referred
to home bedding as being as low your
child has a full-time PhD tutor and
that's the way to treat it is to imagine
that you can really help them guide
their own learning and this is really
valuable so tip number five is to take
advantage of the massive world of online
resources there's absolutely loads of
things out there there are sites
dedicated to home education there's
twinkle which is a really good teacher
which all site the tes has handouts and
printouts available there's conquer math
which is a brilliant daily math program
some of these you pay for some of these
are free some have a mixture of free and
paid content there's absolutely loads of
us so you don't need to worry about
worksheets and curriculum based
activities but there's also a lot of
brilliant online resources that you
might not have thought of so English
Heritage I think do lots of school-based
downloads and videos and things most of
the galleries are doing virtual tours
which is really worth looking at so if
you go on any of the major galleries
they're doing walkthroughs which is
great for you and your children to
explore together and the music lots of
the main orchestras are doing live
concert performances the Internet is
your friend in this situation your
children don't think of it as something
that your children are going to be glued
to all day think of it as something that
you can use together so you can watch
concerts online you can work through
tutorials together it's something that
can really help you all bond and know
that everybody else is doing the same
just to summarize lots of people at home
educate all day every day I've been
doing this effectively for eight years
and I'm still smiling and I still really
love it this is a really good
opportunity for you to get to know your
children to know what motivates them to
know what excites them to know how they
learn and to know what they need to
learn and you might learn something
about yourself in the process